just with what you do i mean it's very
dangerous you know i'm most known for
free soloing and so you know i'm sure
that's what you're referring to as as
you know incredibly dangerous
and uh and
you know that's
that's probably a fair
characterization today on the pretty
intense podcast i have alex honold he is
famous for the documentary free solo he
free soloed el capitan and blew all of
our minds i saw it years ago and thought
this guy's crazy what you'll find in the
interview is that he's not that crazy
he's actually really calculated he's
really calm and sure that's what helps
him make good decisions so that he
doesn't fall off of these uh rock faces
he's passionate about climate change we
talk about that a ton he has a virtual
reality film on oculus that you can
check out and he also has a new national
geographic tv series called on the edge
i don't know about you but i can't wait
to see what he does next if you like
this podcast and you're interested in
seeing more of them
and you want notifications make sure you
click on the subscribe button so that
you are aware when the next awesome
interview is out are you you're you live
in vegas i think or something yeah yeah
i live in las vegas i'm i'm here at home
and uh i've been here for the whole
holiday season basically i've been here
for months because uh my wife is
pregnant and due in uh five weeks now
so uh yeah so we're getting close to the
end oh my gosh how does she how does she
feel how do you feel
i feel i would say i'm starting to feel
slightly more apprehensive and she is uh
she is definitely starting to feel quite
pregnant i think she's she's peeking
i feel like it's something like a pound
a week at the end the last like exactly
a month or so so she's probably in that
she's she's fully in it actually uh the
more interesting thing that she learned
from one of her little pregnancy apps
that she's supposed to be gaining a
finger's width of uh of girth each week
so she's gaining a finger each each week
which is uh
starting to be noticeable
she seems very pregnant
it's kind of fascinating what the human
body goes through i mean watching a
woman's body it's like your skin can do
that yeah no it's uh it feels like it's
pushing the limits of what what skin
should do
yeah no kidding when did you guys get
married uh we got married last year
we've been together six years yeah i
remember watching the doc years ago and
you guys were obviously just dating at
that point in time and then she made you
fall off of a side of a
side of a climbing face cliff how would
i say that a rock face uh she
accidentally dropped me while while
lowering me off the thing it's sort of
complicated it was kind of my own fault
but uh but yeah basically she just
dropped me like 10 feet so kids like
this is a big decision
in general but then when you package
that big decision in with what you do
it's like i
i feel like it's so loaded did that even
play into the decision or
just with what you do i mean it's very
dangerous
well it's
it's complicated i mean it's a
it's not i mean being a professional
climber isn't fundamentally that
dangerous
and within climbing there are tons of
different different aspects to climbing
you know i'm most known for free soloing
and so you know i'm sure that's what
you're referring to as you know
incredibly dangerous
and uh and
you know that's
that's probably a fair characterization
but the thing is i'd probably be a
professional climber either way even
without the free soloing you know just
based on all the other
things that i like to climb and ways
that i climb and expeditions that go on
you know other things that i contribute
to climbing and so
you know
i don't know we'll see basically
um
in the last year i've actually did quite
a few solos that that i was pretty proud
of
but i haven't quite had any hunger for
it with the with the baby coming but
part of that is just because
because there's a baby coming i've been
focusing on certain things
closer to home
and and they just aren't soloing
projects i don't know it's just it's
just complicated you know it's like
where do motivations come from what
really impacts them you know it's hard
to know for sure well what's the
motivation right now then with with goal
setting
you know i often set my goals around
what's available like what's
what i'll have the opportunity to
actually try because you don't want to
set goals that are totally unrealistic
because if you know that you won't be
able to go on a trip to that place or
actually try that specific climb there's
no point in setting it as a goal if
you're never going to get to go there
and so
you know with the with our daughter
coming in a month all of my goals right
now are focused around things that are
accessible at home like basically
realistic goals that i can work on at
home and so those are all sort of like
training goals and fitness goals and
things that that uh that align well with
with having a kid so those types of
goals are are fundamentally not
dangerous you know it's all like in the
closet next to me like you know six feet
away from me is a different closet and i
have a hanging board like some some
training tools set up in that closet so
i can like work out at home with weights
and things like by dangling off little
edges and so i mean there's literally
nothing safer than doing workouts in
your own closet
you know
far fall yeah exactly and so those are
the types of goals that i'm working on
with with the kid on the way
and so the thing is though then
eventually i'll take that fitness i'll
take that climbing ability and hopefully
use it for more interesting things
outdoors but until we have a sense of
what having a daughter is like you know
it's hard to make those plans because i
just don't know what will be available
you know what the opportunities are sure
you said that if you weren't free
soloing because that's the big thing
that you're known for because yes it's
absolutely freaking frightening um and
most people can't wrap their head around
any of it whatsoever no people wouldn't
even climb on top of their roof without
a ladder so you know you're
you have to understand the perspective
here um
but uh what uh what do you feel like
you're next i mean like what's the next
thing if you were gonna use this fitness
what would that next thing be i don't
know that that's hard to say because
with freestyling
you know it's hard to imagine anything
much bigger than freestyling all cap
which is what i'm sort of most known for
with the film free solo
you know there are plenty of other
interesting challenges out there i mean
uh earlier this year i did this this
link up like a combination of three sort
of famous routes uh near my home in red
rock in las vegas
you know so they're always interesting
challenges that you can make for
yourself like that by combining classic
roots and doing
you know things that are new for you or
that are challenging but no matter what
i come up with like that it's not going
to match the
the grandeur of el cap let's say sure
and so
so i don't know i mean but that's kind
of the
the interesting thing about being a
professional climber is that there's a
there's a big creative process to it you
constantly have to come up with
interesting goals come up with with
challenges you know think of what's
inspiring like what you know what what
gets you out of bed i mean there's no
there's no playbook for it you know
there's no rules for it you just you
just have to figure out what what seems
you know appropriately exciting which is
skewed for you um so what uh
what um what would you do you were
saying like if you didn't if you weren't
free soloing you would still be climbing
and you'd still be doing all these
things how do you make money climbing
and what kind of ways to create revenue
stream
and make a living out of it would you be
able to do if you didn't sort of have
the
movie come out and and all of the things
that come around it and then of course
like i know this world well when you get
known for something then you get
sponsors and all these things is that
all still happening on a smaller scale
if you were doing that or is it more
like private expeditions or
you know what would you what would the
what would the business of climbing look
like if you took like free solo out of
the equation and doing things crazy like
that that you're getting so much
attention for
yeah that's that's the interesting
question i mean it's probably
fairly similar to the racing world in
that the
or really any professional sports where
it's like
there's
you know so you can make money for
through competitions and just direct
earnings and things like that though i
personally don't do competitions you
know like kline was in the olympics for
the first time this summer and so the
the climbers that competed in the
olympics they almost certainly have
incentives and things like that from
their various sponsors where like if
they podium they make more money things
like that
so some climbers make money directly
through competitions
i don't i
historically made most of my money
through sponsorship through like brand
partnerships with um you know climbing
specific companies and apparel companies
like i'm sponsored by the north face
they're
typically climbers make the most money
from their apparel sponsor because
apparel is just like a bigger category
than than climbing hardware
um you know as you can imagine because
you see tons of jackets out there in the
mainstream world but you don't see that
many people walking down the street with
like climbing hardware yeah equipment
yeah exactly like their hardness on or
they get it and then beyond that
many professional climbers make money
through sort of odds and end stuff like
writing things and like appearing in
little films and you know just like
random extra i don't know like
promotional things and whatever uh you
know teaching clinics like guiding you
know all kinds of like various side
things
and then for me personally since the
film free solo my corporate speaking has
become much or just kind of public
speaking in general has become a bigger
part of everything
um and even just like movie royalties or
like commercials you know things like
that
um
but so i think if if it weren't for the
film free solo
it just would be the same but everything
toned down a little bit
you know it's like it would be the the
same buckets like the same
possibilities but just all like turned
down to seven instead of 11 let's say
yeah you know well the last time i saw
you was at a speaking engagement so
exactly i had a couple books for next
week and
all this outbreak stuff is happening i'm
like damn it do you like the speaking
engagements
i personally
do
yeah i mean i find it incredibly varied
the thing i feel like i learned
something interesting at every event
because they're always in
i don't know they're always somewhere
new with interesting people smart people
and you know industries that i don't
necessarily understand that well and so
like i did a remote speaking thing
recently for um
for uh some cryptocurrency
stuff and like i don't i personally
don't know much about crypto and i was
like oh it's actually a pretty good way
to learn quite a bit in a fairly short
amount of time so i was like that's you
know that's fine that's cool
yeah yeah
yeah i i find them i actually really
have fun with them i think that they're
great
maybe it's because in the podcast i ask
questions and i try and shut up as best
as possible and when i do speaking
engagements i have an opportunity to
talk and so i'm like i'm also really
like doing that so yeah yeah exactly um
i know i mean realistically when it's
like someone is paying you money to talk
about yourself you're like is there an
easier gig in the world you're like it's
pretty it's pretty chill
to just tell stories about the stuff
that you love most in the world anyway
you know like i could talk about
climbing with my friends all day long
because i love climbing and i'm like
wait if a stranger is willing to pay me
to talk about climbing i'm like well
that sounds pretty chill it's like
that's that's what i do all day anyway
it's so funny i mean it does it it it's
like i think about that too and i think
about you know the business of speaking
engagements and just sitting there for
an hour and chatting about your life and
i'm like wow this is like stealing candy
from a baby yeah exactly but on the
other hand like you had to live the life
that you had to get that gig
you know i had to go live the life i had
to get that gig you know we had to go
spend decades we had to go risk our
lives um to be able to speak from that
place and so you know for sure i think
about how easy it is but um the reason
that you're there is because
of all the things that you've done so i
think i heard you've climbed on all
seven continents is that right yep yeah
actually uh i like that i've put up new
routes on all seven continents
oh wow that's beyond it um okay so i'm
most fascinated with antarctica is there
anything you want to tell me are there
aliens down there are there tunnels
going inside of stuff that you're like
hey what's that and they're like whoops
and they make you you know look the
other way
i mean is there anything crazy going on
down there well so for context we were
climbing in an area called queen modland
which is uh south of cape town so i mean
most people when they talk about going
to antarctica they go from the tip of
south america we went from the tip of
africa
um and so we were on sort of the other
side of antarctica and then we were in
an area that's like quite a ways inland
uh so away from the coast and so there
were actually
basically no living things the whole
trip because you're
you're in a
vast expanse of actually other
interesting fun antarctic effect is that
uh where we were at least and i think
most of the continent is actually a
desert because there's no precipitation
i mean it's it's ice it's all ice and
snow but there's so little precipitation
because the temperature is so low that
there's no humidity
like basically there's no precipitation
like it never rains because it's too
cold for that
and so
and and it's not like it's not like it's
snowing like there are no storms because
it's basically too cold for the the air
to hold humidity
and so
um so anyway it's kind of this
interesting like
you know alien world because there's
there are no living things there's
no
climate you know i mean there's heinous
wind and like it's very cold but uh but
yeah i was like it's pretty pretty wild
i mean where we were there were these
birds uh snow petrols that come in from
the coast to to hatch their their young
because they're no predators so it's
like a safe space for them to come and
have their kids and uh so for the month
that we were there all we saw were snow
petrols from time to time it's like one
species of bird that's it and then late
in the trip i found something that i
thought might have been like in on on
one of the rock walls and i was like oh
my god it's a living thing but i have no
idea if it actually was you know it
could have just been some like weird
rock thing but uh but i was like this is
it's a pretty barren landscape it's just
rock and ice well i think those were
probably baby dragons and
the living things were underneath the
ice sheet not above it
um
really deep it's crazy because the ice
sheet is so thick there i mean we were
at something like 7000 feet and
technically you know the ice goes all
the way down to sea level roughly so
it's like thousands of feet of ice where
do you climb then i mean if it's just a
sheet of ice like where's the sheet of
ice with with like actually since you're
into dragons it's like dragon's teeth
like these crazy spires of rocks
sticking out of the ice so these like uh
up to two or three thousand foot granite
faces like imagine yosemite but still
with thousands of feet of ice below it
and and the the rock was much worse but
but
ice
yeah so it's like
jagged granite walls sticking out of
actually uh
all right i was like do i have a picture
of it in my in my uh you know i've got
some pictures around the uh the office
here your newly decorated office yeah
exactly exactly uh but no i mean uh just
think like mountaintops sticking out of
a glacier so it's like everything is a
flat sheet of ice except for these like
teeth sticking out every once in a while
i bet that looks so crazy it's crazy
it's it's an insane landscape and uh i
mean the specific area that we were
climbing is called uh in or it's like
norwegian it's historically norwegian
but it's called the wolf's jaw because
it looks like it's a big u-shaped uh
sort of valley and it's like oh it looks
like a jagged jawline
you know it's all the teeth of a wolf
it's so cool or yeah except they're 2000
feet dragon or wolf whatever yeah
just rot does granite get i mean is
there a texture difference between
when it's 75 degrees versus
that kind of granite where it's freezing
it's not so much because of the
temperature but there's definitely a
texture difference based on what has
happened to the granite over time so
like yosemite is incredibly nice granite
because yosemite was glaciated in the
past and now the glaciers have retreated
and so as the glaciers scoured down the
valley and then retreated
it like buffed the site you know imagine
like a countertop getting buffed and so
now the walls in yosemite are like this
beautiful perfect clean rock but then
you have somewhere like antarctica which
hasn't had that kind of glacial advance
and retreat you know it hasn't had that
like scouring action of ice rubbing over
it it's just been like sitting there
sort of untouched for thousands of years
uh anyway the rock and antarctica very
bad it's like really really great like
sandpaper like just
like uh like crumbly kitty literally
like if you imagine kitty litter like
held together by like compaction that
doesn't sound safe alex that does not
sound safe
it it was not actually we climbed i
climbed like 15 roots or something while
i was there like basically i climbed
every one of the teeth in the jaw except
for one of them and um
and toward the end as we were doing
harder routes we would climb a really
hard route and then i'd spend the whole
next day in the in the cook tent just
like spooning nutella by myself all
shell shocked to be like oh i don't want
to have to go climbing again and then
the next day we'd be like oh man and
then we'd go and climb another thing
it's like there it was pretty scary so
each one that we did you'd be like oh
god it was kind of heinous then you
spent the whole next day just like
sitting around being like i don't want
to have to go again but then it's like
you're in antarctica it's pretty hard to
get there and so you kind of have to
make the most of the expedition and and
you know climb as much as you can just
sometimes situations like that lead to
bad stuff like lead to bad places like i
feel like it's almost like feeling like
this analogy of a pilot where
you know or or someone that's you know
doing something dangerous and but
especially pilots come to mind where you
make one decision that's a compromise
and then it kind of leads to another
thing and then all of a sudden you find
yourself in a really shitty spot like
yeah
yeah the cascade of earth i mean i have
so many adventure tales actually a lot
of adventures from like rest day hikes
and things uh you know like where i'm
adventuring the mountains going for some
hike and then through a series of sort
of poor decisions you're like and then i
wound up wading through a lake in the
dark the rest of the way home because i
you know like that actually that is an
actual thing that happened um you know i
didn't have a light and then it was dark
and then i couldn't bushwhack along the
this hillside and so i wound up getting
into this lake and i wanted like waiting
the whole length of this like two mile
long lake in the middle of the night
because i like couldn't find my way back
to my car you know [ __ ] like that where
you're like you're like how many bad
decisions did i have to make to wind up
wading through a lake through the night
you know yeah no i have tons of things
like that
have you ever had to climb a tree to get
away from an animal or something like a
bear
no that that i've never had to do
any animal attacks whatsoever
moose um
not attacks i don't think
no i mean the opposite i've had bear i
saw a mountain lion in real life just
for the first time just this year which
was kind of exciting for the first time
yeah mountain lions are so cagey like
you never see them i mean i see their
tracks all the time uh in like snow and
stuff around here but you rarely
actually see them online and then i saw
like kind of a juvenile like a
medium-sized one and i was like
it's still uh i was like that's a
mountain lion it's like pretty exciting
it's like damn yeah i i have this
secret obsession idea with like wanting
to pet a mountain lion or uh uh
even coyotes or i had a cheetah at a at
a game reserve thing in namibia and uh
it was like a giant house cat
it's like
kind of intense still be a little
careful though
yeah well i didn't feel like you had to
because it was it was tame i guess i
don't know
yeah we were in a park and the woman was
like pet the cheetahs it's totally chill
and you're like if you say so i guess
they're sedated yeah yeah exactly no it
wasn't sedated it was crazy it like it
would lick you and it's its tongue was
like sandpaper like you know how a cat's
kind of like that but when you have a
giant cat it's like really like
yeah
i see those cat videos on instagram like
when i'm looking at my search feed and
there'll be some lion or tiger doing
something awesome and i'm like that's my
dream
that's my dream to have a lion jump over
on the couch and cuddle me
well you know
i feel like you could make that dream
happen if you try it hard enough
probably probably i don't know if i'd
like to tell you
so i'm curious if like on these
expeditions there's any kind of
spiritual aspect to it like have you
ever had any kind of different moments
where you there was a sense or a feeling
or a
you know something that sort of
transcended where you were at or even
just you know the experience itself
teaching you things
i'm sure it teaches you things but
something in a more sort of like
you know spiritual way
yeah and not not so much i mean i'm an
atheist i've always been pretty overtly
un spiritual
that said i mean being in some of the
most beautiful
natural locations on earth i mean you
know it's easy to experience feelings of
grandeur and awe and and
i mean just
i mean that feeling of oneness with the
world and things like that i mean a lot
of those those sorts of
experiences are what people characterize
as spiritual experiences
you know i mean that's how how john muir
historically wrote about yosemite valley
you know as a cathedral and uh you know
he sort of wrote about it in spiritual
terms and i you know i've spent at this
point
i don't know something like three years
of my life in yosemite valley so i mean
i've had tons of
of experiences like that i just wouldn't
necessarily
characterize them as spiritual you know
i'd just be like oh i've had very
powerful moving experiences in yosemite
you know it makes me care about the
natural world it makes me care about the
environment you know it makes me love
that specific place but you know i don't
necessarily need to attribute that to a
higher power sure sure yeah we could put
in a different title i mean everybody
uses different words for
the senses that comes over you whether
it's spiritual or
religious or
just nature or just the world or just
energy or whatever it is um are there
i'm kind of curious what the most
beautiful places you've been but also
even you know you're talking about just
places like yosemite are there places
that you go that just have a different
energy
i don't know
i mean depends what i mean
yeah it depends what you mean by energy
so um actually above me in the in the
screen right there i mean you can see uh
that's uh that's patagonia that's like
southern uh southern top picture of the
bottom picture the top one is yosemite
the bottom one is patagonia wow um but
patagonia is kind of
again like a more active version of
yosemite it's like huge granite walls
except it's still glaciated um though
actually sadly the glaciers are
retreating semi-quickly but uh
from climate change
not from like natural you know yosemite
style like glaciers retreating over 10
000 years but a place like patagonia or
or some of the climbing areas in alaska
have a feeling like they have a power to
them in that the landscape is like
so
grand and so alive like you hear
avalanches non-stop you hear glaciers
moving you hear spontaneous rock fall
non-stop like as snow and ice is moving
it like lets rocks loose like basically
the landscape is constantly moving
especially in alaska it's like you
constantly hear avalanches off different
sides of mountains and there's like ice
falling and cyrax falling down and like
you know crevasses opening and closing
like you know because glaciers are
constantly moving
and so that whole landscape is alive and
like you hear it moving and stuff is
breaking and crashing and crumbling and
and so there are definitely some alpine
areas in the world that have that sense
of power i mean like when you're camped
on a glacier in alaska
everything around you is like vast and
powerful and can kill you and you're
sort of like oh geez you know it makes
you feel very insignificant because like
while you're like laying in your tent
reading you're hearing avalanches like
all around and and you know if you were
too close to any of them you would die
and you're just like this is
this is a lot you know it's a it's a lot
to it reminds you how insignificant you
are in the world you're like yeah let's
go into that because that's what you're
doing i mean you're headed no no no no
you're not you climb the roots in
between them
like you know because you have to you're
hugging the glaci the glace glacial
slide
no no like huge granite walls and then
the gullies on either side of it or like
you know basically like uh if you think
of a huge rock face you know there'll be
natural like folds and and weaknesses in
it and so snow will accumulate and slide
down those those like natural
depressions so as a climber you try to
climb the parts that stick out and that
don't accumulate snow in that way so a
big part of of being successful on
expedition is sort of choosing the right
lines and making sure you're choosing
something that's safe from objective
hazards you know something where it's
like isn't going to be hit by avalanches
isn't going to have rocks falling down
it so it's nice to climb uh
like a rats or like ridge lines
basically things that are kind of
sticking out like a spine of rock
because there's nothing to fall on you
does someone have to go clear the path
to like well no i mean that's that's you
if you're doing the first ascent that's
you when i was on bear grylls show have
have you been on his show yeah yeah i
have i had a great what the hell is he
gonna get you to do that you've never
yeah
no for me it was like an active rest day
it was totally lovely we had a nice time
we it was it was super fun actually he
was he was really chill about it he
basically let me sort of guide the whole
thing and he was like we're just having
a nice chat it was really fun but he did
take me skydiving which which was kind
of scary oh great that i did that too
but um we we did all heights stuff for
me which was really fun but you know
at one point when we rappelled down a
little rock face and i'd lean into the
rope for the first time i mean yeah it
scared the [ __ ] out of me like i'm like
oh god here we go ended up realizing
that was nothing compared to what i'd
have to do later but um but he went down
first so he could kick the rocks and get
him out of the way and make sure that it
didn't fall on the next person and
but yeah we did jump up we had i had to
rappel across a canyon and then um
and then do you guys ever have to do
that like when you're doing your
expeditions and you have to get from
point a to point b
i mean do you ever go across canyons and
do that kind of stuff or you always
really leave and then climbing that kind
of going across a rope like i assume
you're talking about like sliding across
a rope to like get across a canyon is
that yeah i wish i could have slide slid
but i had to drag my hand over hand that
normally is used to cross rivers or like
sort of chasms
um but yeah i mean there are definitely
places actually like in patagonia that i
was just talking about to cross a bunch
of the rivers there there'll be a rope
already stretched across it and you just
get there and have to hand over hand
across the rope
but
you know it just depends though because
if you're the first person to ever get
to a place like that then you know
equipping the rope like setting it all
up requires somebody to swim across the
river with a rope on you know which is
no easy feat either and so
typically you're only going to rig
something like that like to set up the
rope if you're planning on commuting you
know go in there frequently back and
forth or something because if you're
only doing it once it's easier just to
swim across the river and you know not
take a rope with you know basically
just get across it once be done with it
yeah which we've i've had to do a lot of
in the past like waiting across rivers
waist deep you know like it's all pretty
chilly
i bet i bet because they're like in the
mountains where snow
river it's cold as [ __ ]
and you have to deal with that i mean
i'm curious about gear i mean i'm sure
that gear makes such a difference i was
also curious about your hands in
antarctica
and the fact that the granite is
basically frozen i would think but like
you can't you never wear gloves right
no so actually in antarctica i did wear
leather gloves quite a bit um just
because the climbing we were mostly
sticking to climbing that was
easy enough for us that uh that i could
do with gloves on
you know
i don't know i'm sure like
you know for for a racing analogy or
something i'm sure if you were driving
at low enough speeds you could drive
with one hand or do it you know what i
mean like at a certain point if the
intensity isn't that high you can kind
of handle extra things like that yeah
and so the climbing that we were doing
in antarctica was like not technically
that intense and so
i mostly climbed with leather gloves on
to save my skin and to feel more
comfortable and then whenever i would
get to the hard parts you can basically
like pull the glove off with one hand
you know shove it into your jacket climb
for a bit and then when you get
somewhere else you put your gloves back
on and with easy climbs like that you
know referring to uneasy climb are you
using ropes at all yeah yeah we were
roped i mean the stuff with antarctica
is that we're doing first ascents of
walls that have never been climbed
before and so you have no idea what
you're going to run into
and then you also have to get back down
and you know i was describing it as like
these big wolf's teeth things so they're
like these spires and uh it's not like
there's an easy way to walk off the back
side you know they're like these giant
teeth sticking up so we'd have to repel
back down and so you kind of need the
full kit like you need your hardware you
need your rope you need everything with
you and also with antarctica
when
when we were in full sun i mean it's 24
hours of sunlight down there because we
were there for their summer so when
you're in the sun it can be
okay you know like comfort wise
because there's no humidity and so if
you're in sunlight like it feels okay
yeah but if you're climbing some feature
and and you're going too slowly and the
sun moves a little bit and now you're in
the shade it's suddenly very chilly you
know like when it gets shady in
antarctica it is very cold and so you
kind of need all the equipment with you
just in case in case you have to retreat
in case you have to like add some more
layers or i don't know it's like it's
not the kind of place where you want to
be like free soloing sort of willy-nilly
because like it's just it's too extreme
basically did you learn a lot along the
way you're like oh [ __ ] i need all these
these certain things i i didn't know how
much i needed this like is there is that
how much like what pieces of what what
articles of clothing or what you know
yeah on certain things you have like
don't get crappy ropes or don't get
crappy you know
what do you put into that you must put
something into the into the rock
actually most of the stuff you put in is
removable so the person who's going
first puts it in and then the person
going second takes it back out and that
way you have all your equipment the
whole time right
um but no you're totally right that you
have to be pretty dialed on on the
equipment
though
you basically learn you know each
expedition so i've gone to patagonia
that picture right there i've gone to
patagonia i think four or five different
expeditions now each time for about a
month
and um
on the first couple trips i would have
like a note on my phone with just tons
of like i should have brought this i
should have had this like use a
different brand of this piece of
equipment you know basically you're
constantly taking notes as to like what
you should be doing differently what
could make things more comfortable like
what would be nicer like how could you
do it better and then you know each
expedition you go on you just learn a
little bit you like tighten up your kit
a little bit but the thing is
you know i mean they're kind of two
things one is that when you're going
somewhere for me like going to
antarctica where i've never been before
you know you read a bit about it ahead
of time you read about other people's
experiences that you can get some sense
of what they needed and what you should
bring but to some extent when you're
going into the unknown
you know it's it's unknown like you just
have to bring a bunch of stuff and hope
that you're ready for you know and then
be ready to improvise it's like
you know it's i mean you just don't know
i mean that's the nature of of
exploration um capturing this all
is probably
one of the parts of the equipment
and so i'm wondering if you ever wear
like equipment i think you were trying
to send me a video i like a virtual
reality video of climbing
hmm
yeah i have the i didn't have the the
killers yeah the headset and um so are
you doing some of the climbing videos
like with yourself do you have gopros do
other people do it do you always have
somebody recording something or do you
sometimes just go on these and it's just
you know
up in the memory bank
i personally enjoy just going and doing
my own climbing and it's just in the
memory bank and i've i've done tons of
things that way
i prefer to let other people document
things mostly because i'm not any good
at it and i'd rather let people who
actually are good at it
you know so
i'd rather just let a professional
videographer cinematographer somebody
like document a climb like you know if
you're going to do it do it right like
let somebody who's a professional
capture in in a
in in a way that actually makes it that
does it justice you know that actually
looks good
um so i prefer not to climb with gopros
or do any of those kinds of things that
said though i mean i do like taking
pictures of my climbing partner and
stuff you know if it's just you and your
partner climbing some big wall in a
remote place i mean i often take my
phone out and take pictures because if
nothing else just to show my family you
know you go home and you're like and
then look what we did it was insane you
wouldn't believe you know i mean i have
i have all kinds of panoramas on my
phone from antarctica and it's just like
any other tourist i'm standing in some
crazy place like holding my phone out
taking pictures because i'm like this is
insane i can't wait to show my wife by
the way they will believe you like
you're not going to believe this but
yeah they are going to believe you yeah
yeah yeah but
yeah so i like documenting but actually
i mean you mentioned
the the vr thing i actually just did
this vr film this year which is kind of
a whole different type of documentation
and like have you filmed anything in vr
no
it's a it's it's kind of the future i
think i found it
it's so immersive i mean if you ever get
to see the film that we shot it's like
totally insane i found it way more
interesting because you know the thing
with 360 vr is like you're watching it
through the goggles but you can turn
around and basically look behind you you
can look down you can look up and so
you know if you imagine a free soloing
film in vr it's like in the center of
the frame you see you know me climbing
but you can look down and see the bottom
if you want you can look up and see you
know the sky you can hear birds in the
distance you can turn around and just
look at the mountains i mean it's like
you can see the whole landscape and so
the film i just shot was um kind of
split between the dolomites in italy and
the alps and
you know chamonix and france
and so
you know if you've never been to those
places it's actually kind of an amazing
way to see the landscape because you can
look around from the summits of these
peaks it's like it's it's really cool i
found it
surprisingly cool so how's that going to
be packaged then are they going to be
movies or
yeah no i think it's just for free on
oculus if you have a headset you can
just watch for free i mean it seems
clear that it's sort of the future of of
entertainment and and uh you know gaming
and things like that but it's just
hasn't quite arrived yet you know not
enough people have headsets like people
aren't actually doing it that much but i
think when you do it
it's kind of an it's insane it's it's
crazy the the vr stuff i do actually
think has a place and it's just it's
it's crazy it's really really cool that
said i don't want to spend tons of my
time on social media so you know it's
all a bit of a bit of a balance
um
but you have social media somewhere
yeah i have the accounts i have a friend
sort of
deal with some of it for me and then
from time to time i basically reinstall
the app and like do something and then
erase the app again
um but it's just better because that way
i don't find myself like because
otherwise i just get sucked into it you
know it's like you like go to the
bathroom and 20 minutes later you're
like i've just been looking at like
weird things and you're just like why
did i do that like is that is that a
good use of my time
wow that's
that's fascinating when did you when did
you develop that discipline or that
awareness
uh sort of on and off over the last
couple years i don't know i mean do you
have all the apps on your phone like do
you actually just get sucked into the
like i get sucked into instagram
sure i have instagram and twitter and i
almost i really don't do much on twitter
it
things come out on twitter but i don't
really use it at a time yeah that's i'm
kind of the same but um and then
instagram i do it doesn't annoy you when
you get sucked into that stuff it does
but then it's interesting and i had an
experience maybe a year or two ago
whenever reels came out where i was like
taking a dump and like reels came out on
instagram you know their version of tick
tock and i was like sitting on the
toilet and i like got sucked into reels
where i was like what is this and then
like i just totally was like engrossed
and then by the time i got up i was like
my legs had basically gone numb because
i've been sitting there for like half an
hour and i was like and then i
immediately erased the app because i was
like screw that i was like this is crazy
and i think part of it is because i
personally have a bit of a
it's partially personality where it's
like when i do things i go deep into
them and it's like you know it's easy
for me to get sucked into something and
like to go hard you know like if i start
watching a show i can easily just watch
the whole season in a single sitting or
something be like okay i did the thing
today or same with reading a book and a
single push and stuff like that like i
like i like going all the way but so
or like actually we just made some some
puzzles you know over the holidays you
know on the dining room table and it's
like you know you lay out a puzzle and i
will work on the puzzle until it's
freaking done a thousand pieces later
yeah like we did we did a thousand piece
puzzle in two or three days you know and
it's just like a
fun you know it's like i'm into it
but it's like the problem is that you
know something like instagram or
whatever else like hijacks that you know
it's like you get into it and then
you're like wait i've just spent my
whole day like looking at weird [ __ ]
that i don't care about that's because
they develop it with special crack in it
so that you get addicted exactly exactly
you know they have the i mean they have
vegas gamers programming yeah exactly
exactly yeah like i don't want to just
universally condemn it because i you
know i think social media can be quite a
useful tool for people for like finding
community and whatever else but i think
that it's not necessarily good for me
yeah
yeah i i
some people are really they like and i
follow some of them and i'm interested
in what they post you know some people
can talk to their phone as if it's a
person and they're just like having a
dialogue and i'm like i just can't do
that like you're like how do you do that
i can't do that if i have to make a
video i'll make a video i've started to
think to myself should i do an instagram
story when i have a podcast come out to
kind of talk about it from my
perspective for like a couple of slides
worth and then
i one came out today that was my like
you know year-end sort of health journey
thing and i was like ah whatever even
though my post made it seem like i was
dying um but yeah i i think it does suck
you in huh i said were you dying no no
but i suppose the first picture is me
with like tons of vials of blood
and like a needle in my arm getting it
drawn you know and then there's another
slide of that and then you know so no
it's it's just blood draws but it's it's
um it probably seemed more dramatic than
it really was but uh social media is
something you get sucked into actually
one of the best things i think that i
ever did was about
i don't know four years ago maybe now i
stopped watching the news
um i still watch tv every now and again
for sure and i'll watch a show but i
don't watch the news
i don't i don't even i've never owned a
tv that's an easy way to avoid all that
stuff hold on a second you used to live
in a van down by the river yeah but now
i own a home and i don't own a
television really
yeah i mean you know we watch shows on
my computer but um but the thing is
yeah also i'm pretty into
downloading shows and stuff offline like
i don't have any streaming services i
just sort of download things ahead of
time and but it makes you much more
intentional in your media consumption
because it's not like what's streaming
and you just click on random [ __ ] it's
like you know if somebody has told me
that i should watch something like i'll
download it and then and then watch it
but it's like there's no there's no
capacity you just get sucked into random
things
but what have you gotten sucked into
every now and again if you were to list
a few things that you're like damn it
and one of them sounds like instagram
one time when you were sitting on the
toilet but other than that what are a
couple of things that you're like oh man
that sucked me in
oh i mean like when i was younger i was
way into gaming you know like as a
teenager and stuff not like um
video games but like computer games of
various kinds and i'd be like into it
you know i'm sort of like i don't know
in some ways i'm glad that i
am not younger because i feel like all
the challenges are just even worse now
because like having a phone in your
pocket like it's really easy to install
a game on your phone that just like
totally hijacks everything in your brain
that you love about like progress and
you know improvement and like working on
little things and like your game is
constantly going it's like it's easy to
get sucked into that kind of stuff i'm
like i don't know you know if i was a 13
year old right now as opposed to i'm 36
and instead you know it's like if i was
13 like i don't know if i would quite
have the
the willpower you know sort of the the
motivation to avoid all these sort of
pitfalls you know because even as an
adult i find it pretty hard to to keep
the apps off my phone and to like
actually read a book as opposed to to
playing some game you know whatever else
i don't know i was like man it'd be hard
if you were a kid
it's true
what are you gonna do with your kid then
yeah i don't know yeah it's a good
question though yeah i don't know i mean
i think that
i'm hoping that the best way is just to
to sort of
show the correct path you know like i
mean not having a television not doing
too much screen time that seems like the
right thing and then i mean i spend so
much of my personal time at the crag
like at cliffs you know outdoors like
going boulder and going to cliffs like
going hiking doing all these kinds of
things i mean i'm hoping that
that by doing that kind of stuff with
the kid
it'll just kind of show a different path
you know you don't have to tell them not
to use your phone you just show them
they're actually more fun things to be
doing in the real world
that's fact
um i'm really curious about your reading
because i know that you read a lot um
what are you reading right now
all right i just started this book
i'm not sure if it's breathe or breath
but do you really read that one about
breathing yeah exactly one though yellow
but mouth breathing well mine's kind of
whitish but you know it's small i don't
know it's paperback but yeah it's uh i
think it's
yeah breathe or breath yeah but uh it's
it's interesting
i last year um some friends had told me
about it and then i listened to some
podcasting about it and i was like oh
this is interesting but now i'm actually
reading the book
and
i don't know i'm only halfway through
i've been uh i've been sleeping with my
mouth tape shot though you know i'm not
the knowledge i'm basically i'm trying
i'm i would say i'm
interested and curious and and
you know trying some things from what
does it say that's so helpful by doing
that oh i don't know i mean you have to
read the book and and it's written by a
journalist it's not like a scientific
uh
you know it's not like a paper or
something i mean it's sort of like a
it's like a journalist's interesting
voyage through you know pulmonary issues
and so
um
i i don't know i don't know the famous
book it's like tons of people have read
that book yeah yeah exactly yeah it was
exciting to see it but i can i know it's
over there on my bookshelf yeah it was
uh it was given to my father-in-law for
christmas and then i basically took it
uh to read it before him because i was
like oh i'm interested in this i'll
finish in a couple days hopefully what
are you most interested in reading about
oh i mostly read i read a lot of
environmental nonfiction but
basically just like things about climate
about the environment just whatever else
i mean i have a i have a non-profit that
supports solar projects around the world
basically like environmental nonprofit
and so
that kind of i founded that sort of as a
result of a lot of different reading and
i mean we've been talking about the
expeditions and travel and all that i
mean it's hard
not to go on trips like that and feel
like you should be doing something
useful i feel like there's a part of me
that's like obviously
climate change is happening and then
there's another part of me that's like
i've watched videos where climate change
happens on a macro level in ebbs and
flows in history of the world and like
what if you're on a rise does that is
that is that part of it um then there's
other people that don't think it's
happening at all but what is
your experience like what is the reality
of it from your perspective
well it's not even from my perspective i
think this is an example where you can
say there is an objective reality i mean
it's like yeah like the climate is
changing i mean it's just
you know how quickly to what extent it's
like yeah scientists still quibble over
some details but it's like climate
change is reality and it's and it's
happening
you know the whole macro scale stuff
basically doesn't
apply to the scale of change that we're
experiencing
i mean that's the kind of thing i mean
what's crazy i mean
i don't know i mean i guess you know for
for your line of work you're not like in
nature quite as much but um dude i'm
killing nature i killed you yeah that's
true
fuel as fast as i can the more fuel i
burned the faster i went so i was not in
the uh most conscientious form of uh
form of work yeah totally totally well
you know never never too late to uh to
change that
but was gonna say i mean so for me
over the course of of my life you know i
can physically see how forests have
changed in california how glaciers have
receded you know it's like or you know i
was talking about patagonia i've done
four or five expeditions there just in
the last six years you know some of the
glaciers have receded enough that you
now hike in different ways to the
mountains that you know like you used to
hike around the south side of the lake
now you hike around the north side of
the lake because the lake is twice as
big because the glaciers receded so much
you know and so when you see
that kind of change happening at that
kind of scale you know because
you know it's easy to be like oh macro
changes you know like yosemite used to
be glaciated and then the glaciers were
treated and you're like yeah they did
over thousands of years not over the
course of one human lifespan you know
basically it's like if you can
physically see change yourself
it's like you know that that the
timeline is totally out of control you
know it's like that's kind of that's why
i find it surprising that there's so
much climate denial and actually i mean
more so in the us than than the rest of
the world but it's surprising because
even if you're like the most staunch
climate denier it's like you can see
that the the flowers in your garden
bloom at different times than they did
when you were a kid or like i'm from the
central valley in california and like
when i grew up like thule fog like
there's thick fog that like blankets the
whole valley and it's like it's a thing
you know there used to be like hundred
car pileups all the time it's like thick
fog all the time in the center valley
and now that happens like maybe once a
winter you know enough to be like oh
yeah there was fog one day but it's not
like all winter the way
and you know i'm not even that old and
i'm kind of like it surprises me that so
many like older
conservative folks can like argue
against climate change in a weird way
because you're like
you know you can see this is totally
different you know like wildfire season
in california is like completely
different scale than it was even 10 or
20 years ago
and and like
you know you can argue the causes about
you know forest management and arson and
whatever else you want to call it but
the results are totally insane you know
what i mean it's like
like the intensity of fires is
like that's not a product of arson you
know what i mean it's not like people
are setting more fires now than where
ten years ago like human activity is
like relatively unchanged it's just that
the intensities are way higher because
the forests are drier and
you know i mean there's
i could ramble about this like so what's
the contributing i mean i think you know
what i love is like what what can i do
right so i mean i think everybody kind
of you know can think about it from a
practical standpoint
but
what are what are the things that
need to be done to really make a
difference and you know i mean i feel
like
me driving a
you know a car a car that doesn't burn
gasoline and then battery powered is an
option but maybe it's the big you know
factory down the road that is like
you know my car is a whisper on the wind
compared to something like that so like
what are the what are the big things
that are really going to move the needle
well that's i mean that's the challenge
i mean there's always the the sort of
contrast between personal lifestyle
changes versus policy sort of issues
right um i mean i think that in the us
there's always been a focus on personal
change we're like what should you be
doing like you should you know drive
green like go electric or go you know
drive a hybrid or things like that like
you know you should turn down your
thermostat things like that and it's
like
yeah i mean those are all or like eat
less meat it's an obvious thing like go
vegetarian or you know go you know
mostly plant-based whatever you want to
call it but um you know basically like
limit your impact and
that all makes sense and i think you
know people should at least think about
those things and do what they can
but the most important things are the
policy things i mean like voting you
know like making sure that that
the government is steering the ship in
the right direction basically
um because realistically
you know it's like you can make certain
lifestyle choices but like
if government ordinances is such that
there are no more new gas hookups in
your county you know it's like basically
if new homes aren't built with natural
gas hookups then lo and behold nobody's
burning natural gas and instead they're
using electric stoves and and basically
that's way cleaner overall and so you
know things like that it's like i think
it's important that the default choices
get greener you know it's like i i
actually i personally sort of don't like
the putting the onus on on individual
action because the reality is that most
people in the us like don't have the
bandwidth and the energy and or even the
finances to like make the green choice
all the time it's like
i think what needs to be done is is that
the the default choices need to be made
a little bit greener you know so like
building codes you know like slightly
denser uh communities with public
transportation let's say or like
you know i mean if new homes are
required to
be net zero so like produce their own
power so they have solar they don't have
gas hookups things like that it's like
those are kind of obvious like
relatively easy things that are put into
code yeah that wind up making an
individual's life much much greener
without them actually having to put any
effort into it
right but i think that probably i'm
gonna guess the snag that comes along
with that is that
it's probably gonna cost some money you
know like
some of that
some some of that though is the upfront
cost is a little bit higher but then the
life cycle cost is much lower you know
the thing with solar and stuff like that
it's like yeah it costs a little bit
more ahead of time but then you don't
have a utility bill let's say yeah and
so you know over the over the lifetime
of ownership it's actually you save
quite a bit of money
but it's just you know there's a higher
hurdle to clear but that's where that's
where smart policy decisions need to
come in you know it's like that's where
there's a place for government and like
tax breaks and things like that and you
know because those are the kinds of
things where i'm like it's not
fundamentally harder to build you know
like not having gas hookups like can be
cheaper actually i mean you know when
you put a new natural gas hookup into a
building it costs like 1500 to like hook
it up to the to the meter and everything
it's like it's not fundamentally more
expensive it's just that it's slightly
different and people aren't used to
doing it that way and you know it's just
not the status quo for a reason yeah
what are the best books that you've read
about this ted oh my god
i don't even know i have like
i don't know so many um
what one got you hooked like what was
the one that got you hooked you know
when did you read and you're like holy
[ __ ] i have to do something well the the
very first sort of environmentally book
uh and actually it's funny i don't even
totally remember what's in the book
anymore but uh it was this book e arth
it's like earth with an extra a in it it
was a bill mckibben book bill mckibben
is like a really renowned environmental
activist who's like worked with 350.org
a bunch and
he's written a ton of books about the
environment in different ways but um but
basically the the premise of earth was
that we're already living on an earth
that isn't the earth that we remember
from childhood which is kind of what i
was actually just talking about where
like when my grandparents talked about
what the world is like like we don't
live in that world anymore like there
are already you know more than 100 parts
per million carbon in the atmosphere
more than there were when our
grandparents were kids it's like and
that literally changes every aspect of
the earth you know like the ocean is
more acidic which means that the
shellfish like mollusks and things make
more brittle shells and like eggs don't
form the same way it's like we've
literally changed every ecosystem on
earth already
and
you know
like that's that's just not the earth
that we think of when we think about
earth it's it's all pretty freaking
heavy you know yeah yeah but it's real i
mean it's reality it's stuff that we're
dealing with i mean you know i think
also about regenerative farming and i
think about um you know hearing from a
few different people that i've
interviewed that we have
60 or 70 harvests left in our soil and
you know
we're just treating our planet
pretty crappy and you know regenerative
farming i think is one of those things
too that
is you know more efficient over time but
you know you have to learn how to do it
and that to me is another example of
like policy things where you're like why
isn't that the default you know it's
like why not just be like like
everything should be that way you're
like it's if it's a smarter way to do it
and it's better long term it's like why
not just do that you know it's like it's
easy to imagine a world that's like
that's better in a lot of ways and
you're like why not implement some of
those things yeah yeah i think i think
that we can all do whatever we can do
because at the end of the day
if everyone is kind of of the mindset
that we take care of this planet in
whatever way that you feel like is a is
a good way then some of those people
that are making those new decisions are
also making the decisions on policies
right like if everyone does it those
people are also decision makers
and as everyone becomes more
conscientious then it would you'd
imagine that it would affect their
decisions
business-wise
yeah the challenge though is that
whether or not that affects change at
the scale necessary to avoid the worst
climate impacts you know because i kind
of agree we're like yeah you know people
are slowly changing and it's slowly
improving each generation is a little
bit better
but the challenge is that if
you know the world warms to to four
degrees celsius the ice gaps both melt
you know sea level rises enough to wipe
out
you know i mean
you know most of the big population
centers on earth are on the coast it's
like if sea level goes up even a little
bit that obliterates all the biggest
cities on earth
you know
it uh
basically some changes need to happen
relatively quickly
and you know the sort of gradual like
generational change is not quick enough
i mean that's that's the
i don't know i read i read a pretty
depressing book which um
which i'm blanking on the name of uh but
uh might come back to me but um but it
was basically sort of looking at an
earth in in like 2050 that's in sort of
a
gradual state of decline overall and and
it's sort of i hadn't really thought
about it you know because we've both
grown up in worlds that you know there's
constant economic expansion like quality
of living is constantly improving people
are constantly slightly richer you know
it's easier to get basic goods like food
costs less than i mean even though the
price
is higher it's actually it's a smaller
percentage of our income than it was
that previously in life like basically
life has been getting easier for most of
our lives yeah and
that's just and it's
easy to see that by 2050 that might not
be the case because a certain amount of
gdp will be going to dealing with like
mega fires and like other climate
disasters and things and you're sort of
starting to see that in california you
know where it's like
two of the biggest fires on record were
this summer the first two fires to
bridge across
uh across the sierra i mean it's it's
like kind of crazy it's like
unprecedented levels of natural disaster
and like as that
as it takes more and more human wealth
to manage those kinds of things
you know that's basically taking away
from what could be the quality of our
lives you know and you're sort of like
oh it's kind of grim to think that my
kids generation
might be living in a state of like
barely making ends meet slash gradual
economic decline yeah yeah that's scary
stuff
um yeah that's interesting i went to
glacier
well i guess it was 2020. um
and
just by the name itself glacier national
american um so i was really curious like
with all this talk how does it how does
it work with glaciers like i i'm seeing
this landscape
huge mountains
it's beautiful
right like it's it's not ice it's real
like grass and trees and all these
things and so
we were all talking and i'm like i don't
really understand how this whole glacier
thing works and so
the glaciers are always
receding and always melting right is
that the
that is that the truth is that real
uh
no i mean well not necessarily because
otherwise they would retreat to
nothingness i mean that's the whole
thing like glacier national park won't
have any glaciers by 2050 or by 2100 or
whatever it is so what happens to the
terrain
well then it just becomes dry you know
then like some of those stream beds dry
up the
forest die off i mean you know it just
depends on the the specifics of it but
no i mean in general a glacier
is
a permanent snowfield like a permanent
ice field basically it's like compacted
snow and so
you know glaciers are formed because
there's enough annual snowfall that
basically compacts down and becomes
permanent ice that's like slowly flowing
downhill
but so
uh
you know if there if it's melting faster
than the snow is accumulating on it then
it slowly retreats to nothingness and
that's what we're seeing on most of the
glaciers on earth right now
got it so they'll it'll dry out and
essentially the the climate in that area
will just be different right there won't
be yeah it'll just be different and
that's actually something that's pretty
[ __ ] up
are we allowed to curse but um yeah yeah
so like um somewhere like the himalaya
like the highest mountain range on earth
in say nepal and northern india and
china
a lot of the the communities there are
fed by
by by glaciers you know it's like
basically their streams coming off
glaciers providing drinking water for
i mean we think india and china are the
two most populous countries on earth you
know that's like
ha what that's a third or half of
humanity yeah it's like a third of
humanity
living off of of that kind of of of
runoff you know i mean yeah and so when
when snowmelt like when snowfields
disappear when glaciers disappear you
wind up with much more erratic supply
for that kind of thing you know you
can't grow crops the same way it's like
instead of having a constant flow of
water coming down you wind up having a
torrent of water come down when it rains
and then nothing the rest of the year
which is like not that helpful for
agriculture because it's either a flash
flood or it's nothing it's like you
can't really grow crops that way
and so
you know i mean glaciers like form the
backbone of of the the hydrology cycle
you know like basically the water cycle
for like big parts of the world are sort
of anchored by glaciers and it's like as
they disappear everybody's [ __ ] wow
so then we have to go find another
planet
well no i mean then you do desalination
i mean you know there are all kinds of
like technical fixes and ways to you
know it's like yeah there are ways to
try to mitigate that but it costs a ton
of money it's a ton of effort like you
know poor like subsistence farmers like
people in in like rural nepal can't
afford those kinds of fixes and they
just basically go hungry i mean that's
the unfair thing about climate change is
that
you know it's basically the poorest
people on earth that suffer the most
from it you know it's like for those of
us living in like suburban america
you know it's like yeah we notice the
air quality being worse in the summer
because the wildfires in the west and
it's like we might notice water scarcity
things but overall we're not going to
suffer in the way that
but you know right now there are a
billion people on earth without access
to power which is some of the work that
my foundation works on
and it's like those billion people are
the people who suffer when the climate
changes like if it doesn't rain their
crops don't grow and they die
and that's [ __ ] up where do you see
your you know your career going because
at some point in time what's the what's
the sort of the shelf life of a
climber's life and i'm sure right like
you could be 70 and climb some easy
stuff right but you know at some point
in time probably the the climbing every
tooth
of the wolf's mouth and antarctica is
probably going to to come to an end at
some point in time and and when do you
when does that naturally usually happen
and then what is the next progression
right now for you that you're super
passionate about that you could see
yourself
um spending a lot of your time on
yeah so climbing has slightly more
longevity than most professional sports
just because it's pretty low impact on
your body so uh so unlike professional
football let's say where you're just
getting hammered the whole time right
you know or really i mean professional
basketball or like tennis you can you
know take tremendous toll on your body
climbing takes much less of a toll on
your body so you can kind of climb at an
elite level probably into your 40s and
50s and then you can probably still
contribute to
contribute to the climbing world enough
to be a professional climber like well
into your 50s or 60s by by sort of
spearheading expeditions putting up new
routes you know mentoring young climbers
things like that
so you can be a professional for a long
time
i do think that i personally will
probably transition to other things at
some point i mean like this um
this upcoming summer i'm doing a
national geographic television uh series
in greenland that's kind of half
climbing adventure half climate change
climate science uh around glaciology and
um so it's like kind of an interesting
way to combine you know some of my
passions and also do a climbing
expedition that feels slightly more
useful because like if you're going to
go and climb in one of these areas you
may as well be be talking about the
issues that really matter which in this
case is the retreating greenland ice
sheet
so i don't know i wouldn't be surprised
if i do more projects like that where
it's like yeah i'm climbing i'm
adventuring i'm doing the things that
i'm good at but i'm trying to do them in
a way that's that's slightly more useful
or like
you know
we'll see i mean the same with work
through the foundation it's like the
huddle foundation
uh
i don't know it just feels a lot more
useful than climbing in a way it's like
you know today i went to the gym and i
trained and i like i hit my numbers you
know i did the things that i was trying
to do in terms of like lifting weight
and like physically pushing myself and
you're like does that matter at all and
i i wouldn't be surprised if having a
kid
uh sort of exacerbates that even more
where i'm like does it freaking matter
if i manage to do my project at the gym
like who cares you know compared to
to trying to
shape the world that my daughter will
grow up in like that seems
you know climbing seems a little less
significant than than focusing on the
bigger issues you're really self-aware
like you i mean i don't know if it's all
the time you have by yourself
you know quiet you know climbing and
just you know sleeping under the stars
and i don't know but where does that
come from
i don't know no no i mean you read a lot
of books spent a lot of time sitting and
you know climbing and you know
but i mean i was also raised but both my
parents are professors uh you know i've
got like a bit of a academic back even
though i dropped out of school and to go
live in a car and go climbing all the
time but you know i mean who knows like
i wouldn't attribute it to anything in
particular i just
i'm just interested in this kind of
stuff
but and as as you know i mean when you
do enough interviews you do think about
issues a lot more and you do
it you know it does
it helps shape your opinions in a way
that's actually pretty useful for you i
always have described interviews as
being almost like therapy yeah like live
therapy where you're trying to sound
like you've got it together trying to
compose some kind of an intellectual
answer as if you've thought about it and
but what happens in the process is that
you do think about it and they do come
up with your answers and
um i've always thought that interviews
are a really therapeutic process do you
think that's the best strategy
and and i ask because uh so i have some
friends who are like hollywood actor
type folks who are strongly opposed to
that strategy they're like
they're basically like interviews are
not the place for you to do your therapy
you know they're sort of like interviews
are where you you stay on brand you
deliver your message you know you talk
about and i've always i've always
ignored that you know i'm like i think
that's stupid because
i prefer you know when somebody asks me
a question i'd rather just think about
it and then give an honest answer
regardless of whether it's you know on
message or whatever it's like
but it also makes it way easier to do
interviews that way because
when somebody asks you just think about
it and you answer you don't have to you
know think about whether or not it's the
right strategy you just answer there's
no problem but
yeah exactly exactly yeah you never have
to stay on message you just always
answer honestly which which is what i've
always been into but
you know do you think that do you think
that's the best way i'm i do i totally
do because i think that when we
when we're communicating from our truth
and what really what we're really
thinking and feeling and we answer the
question honestly like how are you doing
today like i'm good it's like um
actually you know i've kind of like i
had a you know something happened this
morning and then you know so i'm kind of
you know i'm a little you know like
answer the question i mean that's
obviously quite a simple one but
i think there's a lot of people
especially when we're talking about the
racing community where it's like oh you
know the go daddy chevrolet today did
you know had a good race and my pit crew
was good you know i mean there's just so
many crappy answers that you get and i
think that part of what's made me
popular is that i answer the questions
honestly and i give my and i give the
real answer i don't sugarcoat it and
there's emotion in it and there's truth
in it and i think that there's a
frequency i think there's an energy in
truth
and i think that resonates with the
viewer or the listener
in a way that is kind of hard to
quantify or see but it can be felt
so i totally think that it's the right
thing to do um
and it's not like i'm airing dirty
laundry or you know like uh you know
divulging
uh private information that i shouldn't
it's just really about
putting some thought to the questions
that's being answered and or being asked
so that your answers can be interesting
totally totally i know so much of us
sports
interviews are like you know i just did
my best for the team today and the team
really came through and you're kind of
like did you say anything like you know
like what do you actually think about it
do you watch other sports
uh yeah not so much live but but yeah i
mean um i grew up my family like
football so i like i at least know
football okay and i like watch sports
highlights and i don't know i've taken
to watching uh
like every once in a while when i'm like
in a hotel or something somewhere i'll
like watch a whole season worth of nfl
highlights you know like on youtube and
little like 10 minute you know it's like
two hours later you're like i watch the
whole playoffs like in little 10 minute
because because the nfl itself releases
little 10 minute highlight things for
each game and so it's kind of a nice way
to to see
you know like a whole freaking yeah it's
like the whole division like conference
totally well i suppose you're you're
probably you're outside in nature during
the day when it's happening and then
yeah
and i have no television
and you have no television yeah
yeah
and the idea of watching the full game
i'm sort of like man three or four hours
to see something that i mean the amount
of time in commercials and people just
walking back and forth to and from the
field you're like dude this is pretty
slow there's like six or eight good
highlights yeah exactly exactly like i i
love watching other sports for the
athleticism and like seeing human
performance like i like seeing other
athletes do what they do and do it well
but realistically in in like a three or
four hour game you know there's only
five minutes of incredible okay actually
i don't want to diminish it too much
because i mean obviously people are
trying hard the whole time but you only
see elite performance happen you know a
few times per game yeah is there a sport
that you think is the most similar to
climbing as far as like uh physicality
like what what's required physically of
you or even mentally like and maybe
they're different maybe there are
different sports that you think that
they that are more of an a better a
better analogy
yeah i'm not sure i i bet gymnastics is
pretty similar uh in terms of
physicality and like range of movement
and and you know executing routines and
things like that um but it's probably
not the best
analogy either i don't know i don't know
i mean climbing is pretty
singular
that's what i like mentally mentally
when you're climbing how does it
describe what that's like
oh it depends um
i mean so if you're doing something that
you've rehearsed quite a bit in the past
that you've practiced a lot that you've
worked on as a climb then mentally it
can be
uh pretty empty you know you can just be
executing
on the other hand if you're doing a
first ascent and so like if you're on
expedition doing a new route in
antarctica
then you're thinking about quite a lot
the whole time you're like evaluating
the conditions the rock you're thinking
about conditions you're thinking about
your gear you're evaluating safety
you're like thinking about all kinds of
stuff to try to mitigate risk and and
you know survive the whole experience
and so
you know i mean climbing spans from like
this incredibly thoughtful like chess
game to this incredibly zen execution of
a physical routine that you have you
know like muscle memory style that you
have totally dialed actually i mean with
racing is it kind of more on the zen
execution end of it where it's like
you're not thinking about stuff you're
just doing everything i assume it's very
reactive i mean that's why experience
pays off in racing is because you can't
plan it you can't execute it you've got
you know
40 loose cannons out there and
everybody's got their own plan and
everything happens differently and the
conditions are different the car is
different and the pit strategy is
different and you know it's all kinds of
stuff so you just have to it's it's
really flow actually i had a buddhist
monk tell me that um
it was probably like my moving
meditation
yeah that's the thing is that climbing
can definitely be like that as well i
was like not always but like but if you
were driving it like a slightly lower
intensity but over an incredibly long
amount of time like if you're doing like
uh what is it the paris dakar or
something like some thousand yeah
there's like the 24 hours of le mans
there's the 25 daytona or um or actually
probably a better example that would be
like the baja 1000 or something probably
where you're thinking more logistics
like what if my motorbike breaks down
and i have to like you know how do i fix
my wheel and things like that like
that's kind of the expedition end of
climbing where you're like thinking
about stuff the whole time it's like you
still have a little bit of that zen
state of like moving meditation but you
also just have so many extra layers on
it that you're just like i hope my bike
doesn't break i hope i'm taking the
right path like am i even on the track
like
you know have i seen any other racers in
the last half an hour like am i just
driving into the desert by accident you
know what i mean like
it's my trajectory one foot off and now
70.
yeah yeah exactly exactly oops
um do you do i mean do you do get
negative thoughts when you're climbing
oh you can i mean yeah you certainly can
and
and if it starts to go sideways it can
certainly spiral into a dark place i
mean that's one of those things like
fear begets more fear in a way you know
it's like if you start to second guess
and you hesitate
and then
you know it's easy for that to all
spiral into into a disaster basically
where you're like i'm getting scared and
then you start to sweat more and then
you're like now i'm definitely gonna
fall off because i'm like sweaty and
gripped and i'm pulling too tight which
means i'm getting fatigued too quickly
and then you're like oh my god and then
you sort of like you can't think
reasonably because it's all falling
apart
it's like
yeah what do you tell yourself
to chill the [ __ ] out
no seriously you might even just say
that like i mean there might be some
mantra you have or it might be chill the
[ __ ] out
yeah sometimes it depends because i mean
to me there's always
is that fear founded or unfounded it's
like because sometimes you're spiraling
into into deep deep fear
but it makes sense because you actually
are an incredibly dangerous situation
and things are actually going sideways
like it did just start to snow and the
holds are getting wet and you're you are
actually [ __ ] and then and then i mean
you still have to pull yourself together
and try to recover in some way
but
there's there's sometimes when your your
brain sort of spirals away from itself
and you get really scared for no real
reason like you have a rope on you're
clipped into gear everything is totally
safe but for some reason you're just
still scared and in those moments you
can just
really just take that deep breath and be
like suck it up here we go and just kind
of like muscle through it a little bit
but there are a lot of i mean yeah yeah
sometimes you do and and you probably
should because if if that fear is
unfounded like if you're not actually in
danger then you probably should just
muscle through it and move on but that's
intuition maybe what do you mean you
know just like something something else
kind of giving you this message and like
hey you know alex um
it's not a good time and in the back
your mind is the sort of like that that
little voice that's saying
something doesn't feel right
no i i don't think i mean i know what
you're saying and there probably are
moments like that in climbing but um
but it's pretty common that that
climbers
uh i mean definitely like recreational
climbers but even like a elite you know
professional climbers will kind of get
slightly scared for no reason you know
where it's like you're just a little
ways above your last bolt so you're
looking at taking you know a 10-foot
fall or something which is totally fine
the rope catches you and it's all safe
and gentle and like that's normal and
fine but it's easy to be in that
position and be like oh this feels like
kind of scary
for like no real reason and like those
are the times where you just have to
suppress the fear and push through
the challenge is knowing when you
shouldn't just suppress it and push
through because sometimes you are
actually looking at a dangerous
situation you shouldn't push on so what
happened when you in the movie when you
went to go free solo
the el capitan and then you came back
like what happened that made you turn
around well basically i got all gripped
i was i was i was i felt uncomfortable i
was scared
and in that case
you know i maybe could have just pushed
through and it maybe would have been
okay but it was somewhat justified
because i sprained one of my ankles
earlier and so it was quite swollen so
it didn't fit in the shoe so i couldn't
feel my toes that well it's like
basically it was too cold and my foot
was too swollen so it's like hard to
know that your foot hold is that you're
putting your foot on the right foot hold
when you can't really feel it and so
you're about to try the most brave thing
that humans you know one of the most
brave things humans ever done yeah
yeah well anyway that's why i didn't do
it you know it was busy i got up there
and i was like the thing is though it's
like i have tons of experience climbing
with numb toes i mean you know when it's
cold your feet go numb and you climb
anyway and it's fine it's just that do
you really want to risk your life to
that when you're not totally sure and
you're coming over an injury you're like
ah you know anyway basically i got in
that
situation was like i don't feel
comfortable with this and so i gave up
on it and then i came back the next
season when i was healed and it was
better conditions and everything about
it was i was better prepared and uh and
then it felt totally comfortable when i
did it so what was the gap time wise
between that that effort that try and
then the one you did uh the failed
attempt was in november which is part of
the reason it was cold because it's like
coming into winter in the sierra and
then the successful climb was in june so
it was like six months later got it for
seven months i guess
what do you think that um
you know what do you think is if we're
being philosophical i have been has been
the greatest lesson that climbing's
taught you
i don't know i don't know it means
probably some life lessons around
effort you know like putting in the time
like working for the things you care
about i don't know is that a life lesson
but like
like embracing the grind you know just
like loving the process and just like
doing the thing all the time and like
not being too results oriented you know
just like
letting the results come
as
as a
as a product of the grind you know it's
like when you love just like doing the
thing day in and day out every once in a
while you're gonna have moments of
greatness you know it's like like if you
do you know i've been climbing full time
for like since i was a kid but so i've
been climbing you know maybe five days a
week for 25 years and at a certain point
it's a freaking odds game you know it's
like if you climb enough days you're
bound to do something good every once in
a while you know
i was thinking of the bad
yeah but
you stop climbing now so that you can go
do all the other things that you want to
do let's not really go for the biscuit
no no it's one of the good things it's
like you know it's like man if you climb
enough you're bound to do something
impressive every once in a while
is there anything impressive left on the
list like is there anything where you're
like man before i close out my
climbing career at this level at the
elite level
there is like these are the these are
the boxes to check these are the bucket
list items in my career still
it's tough it's a little bit of
diminishing returns at this point
because nothing is going to be as cool
as i'll cap and it's yeah and it's like
harder and harder work for me um
partially because i'm getting older i
would assume but um but also just
because i'm already close to my
limits you know it's like basically i've
i've put a lot of effort into climbing
for a long time so it's not that easy
for me to improve at this point but um
you know i've gotten like at least close
to my physical limits but
no i don't know there are a few things
like i'd like to climb harder grades
like climbing is is graded by certain
numbers um i've never climbed 515 it's
like a certain
number um i'd like to get there i'm like
kind of close we'll we'll see i think
that um that fatherhood is a good
opportunity to to pursue that because um
for me climbing at that grade requires
sort of a structured training pro like
it requires uh
a degree of of
of structure in my life and i i think
having what's the difference but what's
what's kind of the what's the difference
of the 515 is
it's just harder it's like smaller holds
further apart you know more continuous
like basically more
physically demanding
um but it's just it's just hard it's
it's the kind of thing
for a non-climber you would look at a
root of that grade and it would look
like a blank sheer wall you know you'd
be like that's a wall of glass that's
impossible but you know obviously it is
possible but
you know
i don't know so climbing harder grades
and then there are a handful of other
things like there are some other roots
in different parts of the world and
things
and and like the the vr film that i did
last year
is like a cool opportunity to like share
climbing in a different way that i
actually think is pretty freaking cool
and and to do and for that film i sold a
couple routes in europe that hadn't been
done before and so it's like a fun
you know i'm like i'm doing something
that that's still
meaningful for climbing it's like new it
hasn't been done before it's cool and
it's being shared an interesting new way
i'm like that you know that's still fun
for me but it's it's not never going to
be the film free solo what about making
a video game what about a video game out
of climbing
i don't know i don't think i don't think
that's my calling yeah i think i think i
think well i think that no video game
would be nearly as cool as doing the
thing itself and
i mean racing games too so oh that's
true that's true but racing games
are so the thing about racing is you
can't really just go and do it the thing
with climbing gyms is that like any
major city in the world now has climbing
gyms where you can do the thing
at whatever level you want and it's
really freaking fun and really good but
like you can't really go race
like you can't get a full race
experience in any city like anywhere can
you
not really i mean you can go you can do
like fun carts like go carts yeah i've
gone golf guarding and i found it i
found it a little scarier than i sort of
expect i thought i was gonna be like
kind of good at it and i was like kind
of bad at it and found it kind of scary
and i was like that's slightly
embarrassing
i was like it turns out i'm not really
suited to the like really fast sort of
like i don't know it all felt kind of
intense a little more calculated does
anyone ever does anyone ever dare you to
do anything
does that like i don't know like maybe
it's i don't know if it's a regular
person or you're climbing friends but
does anyone go
jump out of the car and go climb that
right now
not so much like that but yeah like with
climbers you know rope swings and things
like that like fun little adventure
things
uh is that ever ended
not too poorly
i had a friend with a rope swing be like
oh you you like
go from a certain point and i would like
got up to a certain point was like are
you sure it doesn't seem like it it'll
it'll work and he was like yeah that's
fine and then i was like okay and so he
was like i'm sure so i went and i
basically just like augered through
these bushes and like i like tore down
this mountainside like through the
bushes all like ah you know thankfully
didn't hit the ground but just like got
all shredded in the bushes and then when
i was done he was like oh yeah i guess
you're supposed to go from a little
higher and i was like yeah no [ __ ] i'm
like almost at the ground all right well
will you please be careful try not to
get yourself hurt don't do more rope
swings
and um
good luck with the baby and
congratulations on on that that's going
to be
i can't wait to see you at some other
speaking engagement that we meet at
somewhere along the way and but then
what it's like
presumably that'll uh it'll mean i'll be
more you know mature and responsible and
all those kinds of things but we'll see
now we just we never really grow up i
mean isn't that what you i'm 39 you're
36 like
you know when you see your parents at
that age when you're young you think
that's old but now we're here and you
realize that you still have no idea
what's going on oh yeah you still have
no idea what's going on and you still
want to do kind of stupid stuff every
now and again you just have to pay a
bigger price
yeah yeah totally
totally
yeah obviously well congrats on a crazy
crazy life
and um almost no one will ever be able
to relate to it but maybe we can through
your vr
ah yeah i mean uh
yeah i do think it's a good way to
experience online i think you'll be
impressed if you get to try it i i
guarantee you'll enjoy the whole you'll
be like this is crazy i like it kind of
blew my mind and i have a high standard
for that kind of thing i was like damn
yeah but anyway no it's been it's been a
pleasure chatting sorry i went so deep
on environmental things but i asked i
start to rant about things and i i just
i can't stop normally you don't go too
deep into that kind of stuff because you
just never know knowledge is power and
you've read a ton of books and you're
engaged personally and physically with
it and you have a lot to say and people
should listen
ah
well thanks thanks i appreciate that
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button